[Music]
I have to answer the texts aunt I
write to him what's cool what we see
him a home with donations are okay be
cool here's the secret world hidden
inside your phone
where updates like me work and
live here each of us we only do
one thing but each time we
have an interest in ensuring incoming messages we
ask blaf acquired way which manufactures 32
faces
what are these themes where j my friend jean
he alleviated the problem for you  but
how do you do that I do it that's all I
know you can help us
follow me you have to get out of the phone
to find the source code for the
chip routes ginette
we have to find the password hello
what is it  the name of alex's girlfriend
already her name is tina sarah would have
said peta but it doesn't sound
great it looks more like the name of a
chihuahua
you know I think it's pretty good the way you
are
[Music]
it leaves me  phone is depriving
slaps a different feeling
maybe I'm not made to be a
single emotion
me I learned like dick roche 2006 and
since never sweets good life I
overdosed
toppe there doesn't do that  don't do that this
thing has already gone into your stomach
what did pistons do after a group
potty what we have to wash our hands
kaka trophy